first of all explain where the title the
lyric and the idea came hello okay but
it all sort of came from the experience
of having a guy cues the compliment
you're not like most girls and having
accepted that as a compliment in the
past sort of hoping that that's what
they would say right I have thought
about it or put thought into it and
realize that it's really not much of a
compliment little do they know thinking
about it again sort of in detail when
someone says are not like most girls and
and most girls are in fact really
amazing and intelligent and beautiful
and strong it just made me sort of think
well what part of me is not like that
and I kind of feel like there's been
this sort of like standard that in order
to be special you have to be so
different from other women and I really
don't think that that's the case but how
do you marry the idea of everybody still
wants to have some sort of uniqueness to
them sorry I mean you still want to feel
right you know that you are a little
special you are like different because I
get through a lot of things in life so
how do you marry those two the only
thing for me personally I mean I know
what makes me happy and I know what
makes me me but I am truly inspired and
have become more and more inspired and
aware of all of the women around me
because you know I think again as I've
had I've had moments where I'll see a
picture of some of a girl or a woman and
think like oh my god I want to look like
that and then sort of be in denial about
it because again like I want to be who I
but it shall pay to want to be I think
it's the that sort of realization of
knowing that it's okay to want to be
like like other women does the guy does
the guy who said you're not like most
girls know that this song is hahaha yeah
you know yeah which is funny because
I've had more of my like close guy
friends say like you are not like any
other person I'm like oh that's not you
know it's a light-hearted they gotta get
like I said little do they know I think
they do give it and mean it as a
supplement right so
yeah so do you have to set somebody
straight down like when did you tell him
before the Sun came out and by the way
I'm going to be doing a lot of press for
this anyway
yeah I think that's been the music get
ready Fred cellar just like sending the
mp3 bulik here oh no you know this went
out I just got out okay perfect perfect
and so when it comes to do you deal with
because a lot of you're young and you've
been in uh students for a long time and
it can be savage on young women the
ratio of you feeling confident to
insecure still with the success you have
as well um
well you know it's funny I I don't know
that I feel it's that big of a ratio I
think well maybe it's pretty even
actually the more that I think about it
because I I have an incredible family
that is my support system in my rock and
I get to go home to them at the end of a
very work day or at least know that I
had them to go to but at the same time I
think you know we're constantly I think
men and women everywhere young and any
age whether they're in school in this
business whatever they're doing are put
in situations where they're sort of
tested or either not considered for a
pible and I think that I'm obviously
faced that and continue to but I think
it's happening less and less especially
with women I think more now than ever
where I wouldn't say given a chance
where we're being seen for our
capabilities and we're standing together
and really lifting each other up at what
point in your career because you've had
it quite the career already at what
point in your career did your family
stop worrying that maybe you were going
to get one rejection too many if it's
going to damage you for life at what
point did they realize that this is
actually going to work for you oh god
where they could sort of lean back right
let you and let me take over I don't
know actually but I do know that I mean
my parents what hasn't happened yet
honestly maybe it happened maybe it
hasn't no it's it's been brutal I mean
I've been doing this for a very long
time and I don't know what it is about I
guess my love for what I do is so strong
because I've been knocked down a lot and
I've just had the courage to keep
standing up and I have a lot of people
to thank for that and a lot of people
who sort of taught me how to do that but
I I know that my parents have had those
conversations it's like do we let her
catch like this but I think they know
how happy it makes me and all they've
done since they want to support me I
heard that you want to would do a song
with Ed Sheeran if the opportunity did
come up well of course who wouldn't
would you
how fast would you drop everything to do
that I mean in a heartbeat I absolutely
I am a huge fan of Joe I am lucky to
call him a friend I think he's an
incredible person and
yeah just genius you have a list do you
have that sort of because collaborations
in duets especially within the last
three four years are you totally there
you can normal not like the American
sort of thing there's huge normal did
you start making a list like a sort of
dream list of people that you would love
to work with because I know you work
with Ryan Tedder on their song and edge
here and we talked about do you have
that kind of that list going oh yeah and
I feel like every day there's somebody
added to that list of artists that I
discover or a new song that I fall in
love with from somebody yeah I mean the
list is very long either just artist
wise producer wise writer wise the more
I the more I do it the more I learn and
discover yeah yes amazing when you do
wind up putting so much of yourself in a
song or on an album feelings come and go
and you may write something that was
from the heart at that time you may
change you may grow your feelings may
change what's it like to sing those
songs that you may not feel that way
anymore or do you ever think about I may
not feel like this again but I'm going
to have to sing the song for the rest of
us yeah it's totally in fact it's funny
because I mean there are songs that I
haven't written yet that are sort of
noted in my phone and I'll go back and
look at it and think like what was I
this is no officious irrelevant and I
was like forays ago 400 but no I think I
think it becomes and I don't know that
I've necessarily experienced that yet
because I still am very much sort of
living what I'm sure living on stage but
I do think that it becomes it becomes
it's about a moment with us with the
fans and the people that are in front of
you and it's sort of it's made me
realize I mean being a fan of music and
going to concerts doing one of my
favorite things ever being in the
audience and literally crying watching
certain artists sort of looking out to
fans I do that to my music it's like
they have a they have a story they have
this vision of something for them yeah
become some no you're just